determine whether the system has no
solutions or infinite solutions so let's
think about how this how we can go about
doing this so if at any point we might
get us we might not have to solve this
entirely if we somehow get something
that's nonsensical which will tell us us
no solutions or we might have to go
further and see if it's one or infinite
solutions all it looks like one solution
isn't an option here given how this
question is phrased so the way that you
would proceed to solve three equations
with three unknowns is you would try to
eliminate variables one by one and so
first we could try to eliminate the X
variables and we could do that we can
essentially create two equations with
two unknowns the two unknowns will be
y&z if we can pair up these equations
and eliminate X with each of these
pairings so for example we can pair
these first two we could pair the last
two and and that's all we would need to
have to eliminate the x's and still have
two equations that have all of the
information of these three equations but
then a third pairing would be the first
and the third equation but we only have
to do two of these pairings now just to
show you what I mean by these pairings
what I want to do is take these first
two I'm going to take this first I'm
going to pair this first pairing right
over here and I'm going to use them to
eliminate the X terms and over here I
have 2x over here I have 8x if I could
turn this 2x into a negative 8x I could
add both sides of these equations to
each other and the X terms would cancel
out and so the best way to turn this 2x
into a negative 8x is to multiply is to
multiply this top equation times
negative times negative form when I say
multiply I'm saying multiply the whole
equation both sides of it by negative 4
so 2x times negative 4 is negative 8x
negative 4y times negative 4 is plus 16y
or positive 16 Y Z times negative 4 is
negative 4z and that's equal to 3 times
negative 4 which is negative 12 and then
I can rewrite this equation right over
here it's 8x minus 2y plus 4z
is equal to 7 and now i can add these
both equations on the left-hand side
these guys cancel out
sixteen y minus two y that was the whole
point behind multiplying the top
equation by negative 416 y minus two y
is 14 y negative 4 is the plus 4z these
guys actually cancel out as well so
actually with that one pairing by
multiplying by negative 4 we're actually
able to cancel out two variables so you
get 14 y is equal to negative 12 plus 7
is equal to negative 5 and you can
actually solve for y and we don't know
if this is if this one will actually
have solutions but if we assume it's
going to have a solution you could
actually solve for y right over here you
could divide both sides by 14 but let's
worry about that a little bit later
let's take the second pairing right over
here so once again you have an 8x we
want to eliminate the X's so this one
you have an 8x here you have a negative
4x if you multiply this times 2 this is
going to become a negative 8x and it can
cancel with this top one so the top
equation is 8x minus 2y plus 4z
is equal to 7 when I say top equation
I'm talking about this one right over
here the top one in this pairing and
this bottom equation I'm going to
multiply I'm going to multiply times
negative 2 I'm going to multiply it
times negative 2 sorry times positive 2
I'm going to multiply it times positive
2 negative 4x times positive 2 is
negative 8x so I'm going to multiply by
2 so 2 times negative 4x is negative 8x
2 times y is plus 2y 2 times negative 2
Z is negative 4z and then 2 times
negative 14 is negative 28 and now we
can add the left-hand sides and add the
right-hand sides these cancel out those
cancel out those cancel out we actually
end up with nothing on the left-hand
side you get 0 plus 0 plus 0 and on the
right-hand side you get 7 plus negative
28 is negative 21 well this is a
nonsensical answers Eero can never be
equal to negative 21 no matter what X Y
or Z you pick 0 cannot be equal to 21
negative 21 and that's because these
second two equations right over here if
you view them as planes in three
dimensions these right over here do not
intersect
do not intersect if you visualize them
in three dimensions they are actually
parallel planes and since these last two
these last two definitely do not
intersect we can say that this system
has no has no solutions it doesn't
matter if this first equation intersects
one or both of these the fact that these
two don't intersect tells us that
there's no unique point XYZ coordinate a
point in three dimensions that satisfies
all three of them because there's no
unique XYZ that can satisfy these two
because these are parallel planes they
do not intersect